[chime]
[beeping]
- Off the coast
of North Carolina
lies a treacherous
stretch of water
with strong currents
and shifting sands.
With the remains of
up to 5,000 ships,
it's known as the
graveyard of the Atlantic.
Hidden within this eerie
resting place for lost souls
are gangs of Sand Tiger sharks.
Photographer and conservationist
Tanya Houppermans
has spent over a decade
documenting the shark
gang phenomenon occurring here.
- I started diving around 2009.
Came down here to
North Carolina,
and that was the first time that
I saw the Sand Tiger sharks.
It literally changed my life.
I walked into work and quit.
I left the corporate
world behind
and decided to devote my life
to spending time with sharks.
- Working with Spot
A Shark USA, Tanya
is studying the thousands
of sharks that have made
these shipwrecks their home.
These rusting hulks provide
the perfect conditions
for marine life to grow
and for predators to hunt.
But why Sand Tiger
sharks congregate here
in such large gangs
is still a mystery.
- There are times that we could
see a hundred and maybe even
more sharks in an aggregation.
They really seem to prefer to be
around other Sand Tiger sharks.
We're not quite sure why yet.
- Today, Tanya and
her husband Scott
are looking for answers
by diving a wreck
known for large groups
of Sand Tiger sharks.
- Today were heading out to
the wreck of the Caribsea.
This is a freighter that
was sunk by a u-boat
during World War II.
Right now, she lies
about 90 feet underwater.
That's where we tend
to see a lot of Sand
Tiger sharks hanging out.
- Tanya is on the front line,
trying to discover the secret
that unites these sharks.
She's taking photographs
so scientists
can study them for vital clues.
- Inside this housing
is the camera that I
use to photograph the sharks.
And we have two lasers
here on each side.
When I take a
picture of a shark,
these two green dots will show
up on the side of the shark.
We can then actually calculate
the length of that shark
just from the photograph itself.
And then we can
go in and identify
each individual shark based
on its unique spot patterns.
It's like a fingerprint
is to a person.
I want to kind of give each
other's gear a look over, too.
[puff]
All right.
Looks good.
Every dive, there's
the possibility
of learning something
new about these animals.
There really hasn't been a
lot of research done on them,
compared to a lot of other
species such as Great Whites,
so any time we get in
the water with them
and bring back any information
for the researchers
that I work with,
it's a great day.
Good, then.
Right.
Let's go find some sharks.
[splash]
[air hissing]
We have 100 feet of
visibility, clear blue water.
A lot of the wreckage
still intact--
you can see the
big bow structure.
It never gets old.
There are just sharks as far
as I can see all around me.
- These sharks are named
after tigers because
of their voracious appetite.
But to Tanya, they're
gentle giants.
- They have these
raggedy teeth that
makes them look really
fierce, but these sharks
are full of personality.
Sand Tiger sharks are probably
about six or seven feet,
the female being a little
bit bigger than the male.
- Surrounded by a
swarm of sharks,
Tanya begins her
search for evidence
as to why so many are here.
- There are a lot of females.
Every so often, you see a few
males, but it's mostly females.
Why is that?
- With her laser guided camera,
Tanya captures her first clue
to solving this mystery.
- Some of the females do
have scars from mating.
When sharks mate, the
male actually holds
on the female with his teeth.
If we see fresh mating scars,
that female may be pregnant.
We're finding several
pregnant females.
Why are they grouping together?
- After photographing
the girl gang--
- That was amazing.
There was a lot of sharks.
- Tanya tries to make sense
of this incredible spectacle.
- So what we're seeing is a
big gang of Sand Tiger sharks,
mostly females.
We have so many
unanswered questions.
But what we're thinking is
that maybe these females
are aggregating together
during pregnancy
so that the males don't try
to mate with them again.
It could be possible that the
females are banding together
as kind of a support network.
They are choosing to
group together like this.
And so not all sharks
are just solo predators.
Sharks could have a social
life, just like humans.
[gentle music]